اهلا نايف في العاصمه باريس حتى الان
الامور هادئه جدا لا يوجد اي اشتباكات او
مناوشات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه لكن في
مدن اخرى تخرجت فيها هذه التظاهرات مثل
مدينه رينونج ايضا هناك اشتباكات بين
المتظاهرين وعناصر الشرطه الشرطه تستخدم
الغاز المسين للدموع هناك حوادث شغب تحدث
في العاصمه باريس قبل انطلاق الموكب اعلنت
الشرطه قبل قليل انها قامت بتوقيف احد عشر
شخصا كان بحوزتهم ادوات حاده وايضا انها
قامت بخمسه الاف واربعمائه عمليه تفتيش في
كل فرنسا
لمتظاهرين كان من المحتمل ان يكون بحوزتهم
ادوات حاده لاستخدامها خلال هذه التظاهرات
وافتعال الشغب كما ذكرت نايف هناك اجراءات
امنيه استثنائيه اليوم خصوصا في العاصمه
هناك
و500 شرطي نشروا فقط في العاصمه من اصل 13
الفا في عموم فرنسا لمواكبه هذه التظاهرات
هناك تخوفات كبيره من ان ت هل هذه
التظاهرات الى اشتباكات عنيفه خلال
الساعات المقبله خصوصا في العاصمه وعاده
ما تبدا هذه الاشتباكات في ساعات المساء
الاولى عندما تزداد اعداد الناس وايضا
هناك تحذيرات كذلك من وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي قال ان هناك عدد كبير من عناصر او
من شبان اليسار المتطرفين الذين يتواجدون
في هذه التظاهرات وايضا هناك اعداد من
هؤلاء قادمه من خارج فرنسا الافتعال حوادث
الشغب طبعا الوضع الامني حساس جدا في هذه
الايام في فرنسا خصوصا وان هناك سته عشر
تحقيقا فتح بحق عدد من عناصر الشرطه
الفرنسيه بسبب قمعهم الشديد وتجاوزاتهم
التي حصلت في التظاهره الاسبوع الماضي
ايضا ايضا هناك نحو اكثر من 100 الف شخص
قاموا بتوقيع عريضه لحل احدى كتائب الشرطه
وهذه الكتيبه تسمى
وهي كتابه تدخل السريع تكون على
دراجات ناريه قامت
بعمليات اعتقال عنيفه جدا بحق المتظاهرين
وكل القوى اليساريه تقوم بادانه هذه
التصرفات التي قامت بها الشرطه ايضا هل
كانت هذه التصرفات بسبب